Hi everyone it's a pleasure to be here thanks
[inaudible] for that introduction. I'm not a national hero,
you have to play soccer and do it well to be national hero.
But it's really a pleasure to be here. As
[inaudible] was saying Mercado Libre basically started in
Stanford almost exactly eleven years ago; it was in March
and I was attending a class, a finance class taught by Jack
McDonald who is still teaching and I used my silver bullet,
I don't know if you still have silver bullets or not. But I
had used my silver bullet to attend his classes and he had,
one day it was before Google and Google images. I always
came to class and sat in the first row, I didn't study that
much, well at Stanford but I really enjoyed coming to class
and to lectures and meeting the people that came to present.
And one day I came in early and a guy was sitting there and
I didn't recognize him and he said 'hello I'm Joe Doe
[inaudible] I'm just dressed up like Warren Buffet today. I
obviously didn't understand the joke so I said aha and I
said alone in a class wit Warren Buffet for five minutes; I
didn't say a word to him. And the guy actually was Warren
Buffet so after that I decided that I had to use Jack
McDonald's contacts and I was preparing my business plan for
Mercado Libre which was an idea that I had, basically having
lunch and dinners with friends here at school. And I asked
him to introduce me to someone he thought might be
interested in investing in a project like mine. And he never
said who is coming to class, partly to insure that everyone
comes to every class. And he said don't say this to anyone
but John Muse was one of the founders of Hicks Muse, will be
coming to class in a month and I will tell him about your
project during lunch and I will set it up so you can drive
him to the airport after the class. So he did and before the
trip two of my classmates stepped into the car, they already
had like ten job offers,
I didn't have anyone because I wasn't looking for a job; I
knew what I wanted to do.
But they were the type friends that like to be near well
known people etc and they monopolized the conversation
during the trip and I was getting really nervous. We were
going down 101 and he had a private plane so it wasn't a
problem if he was there late. And so kind of half way
through the trip he asked me so what are you going to do
after you graduate? And then I started with my pitch which I
had rehearsed a hundred times but I knew I wouldn't have the
time to deliver all of it, so I had to take the wrong exit
and took him to the commercial airport first, pretending
that I didn't know he had a private plane. This was also
before 911, so after that we went to the private airport, in
those days you went with the car to the plane. And he
stepped of the car which was parked right next to the plane
and took his luggage and walked up into the plane and I was
standing there with my two friends and he left the luggage
and he walked all the way down and he told me next to my ear
'your story is fantastic and I'm fascinated by it and I want
to invest.
Obviously my two friends didn't quite hear what happened and
they were extremely anxious that I was still so angry with
them I refused to tell them. And I had already bought
tickets to go to Europe with my girlfriend after graduation,
so I got home and I told my girlfriend 'I'm sorry but the
trip has been cancelled' and we ended up going to Europe six
years later.
But that's how Mercado Libre started and it's a true story
and it happened here in March of 1999. So with that, the
idea today is to give you a brief overview of Mercado Libre
and make this very interactive so feel free to interact with
questions as we go along. And afterwards if you don't, the
presentation will be over in less than probably 20, 25
minutes maximum. And then we'll have time for Q & A.
So the origins of Mercado Libre as I mentioned; they started
in June of 1999. This trip was in March of 1999, we started
the company in June and we launched in August as an online
auction service in Argentina but we quickly expanded
regionally. We then did two rounds of financing. We did a
first round of financing in October of '99 where John Muse,
Hicks muse invested, it was around 4.7 million dollars and
they were joined by Chase Capital at the time.
And then we did a second round of financing in May in 2000
for 46.5 million dollars which was led by Goldman Sachs. And
obviously the first round investors also participated and we
had a few other investors like GE Capital. So during 1999
and 2000 basically we expanded regionally, hired a great
team, many classmates from Stanford, leading each one of our
different subsidiaries.
In 2001 we partnered with Ebay. They had acquired a European
company that had a subsidiary in Brazil that was a
competitor of ours and in exchange for almost 20% of Mercado
Libre, they gave us that subsidiary and we signed our five
year strategic partnership and non competition agreement,
In 2002 we bought a Brazilian competitor called
[inaudible], which was a strong local competitor in Brazil.
In 2003, four years after the launch, we really started to
see some growth in the business. Before that it was all
financing and marketing and focusing on product but not
really that much traction in the business. So that's a big
change from what you see today; companies like Groupon that
went from nothing to rumors say three billion dollars in
revenue this year in two three years, it's a much bigger
internet and many of the bottle necks that existed eleven
years ago have been solved, like payments for example.
In 2004 we launched our payments platform and we learned a
specific business model for classified. In 2005 we broke
even and we acquired
[inaudible] which was a regional competitor which was
launched right when we launched by a group of Harvard MBA's
so that was a huge battle, that's also something I enjoy
telling Stanford grads.
Specially when they ask me to call admins that have been
added to both schools, I tell them the story; it works quite
well. But it's a fascinating story because they were all
Harvard MBA's and we were all Stanford MBA's and we were
competing in all of Latin America. And we built a great
company and they got acquired by us in 2005 for 12 million
dollars we bought half of the operation and in 2008 we
bought the other half for 50 million. And today Medcado
Libre is valued at almost 3 billion; so Standford is better
than Harvard.
In 2007 we IPO'ed, we did a three hundred and thirty three
million dollar IPO which was a huge event because there
weren't any tech IPO's those days and the day that we priced
was the first time since 911 that the European central bank,
the FED and the Japanese central bank, together had to
intervene to provide liquidity to the markets because it was
when the sub prime crisis was already at full speed and
there was a huge financial mess, which lasted obviously for
several more months. We were quite unlucky, however the IPO
was very successful, unfortunately we priced at 18 that day
and the stock closed at 28; so we left a lot of the money on
the table there. And it's been going up since then.
In 2008 we also acquired a classifieds player called tu
carro that is very strong in Venezuela and Columbia. And
more recently in 2009 we launched two new businesses called
Mercado Clics and Mercado shops. As you can see we're very
original with our names.
Let me talk briefly about Latin America. It's a very
interesting region, the one that we operate in. it has a
very good combination of actually GDP; population size and
expected growth. We have almost six hundred million people
in the region with a GDP per capita of close to nine
thousand dollars and a total GDP close to five trillion
dollars.
In terms of internet we are seeing very strong growth but
importantly we believe we will continue to see very strong
growth going forward because in relative the internet
penetration and broadband penetration is still quite low in
the region. But it's growing very fast. So we believe in the
next ten years we will continue to see very strong growth in
our business and in our industry.
So this is the projection for e-commerce growth in relative
terms. Latin America is still quite small but growing very
fast relative to the other regions in the world and we
believe this is going to continue being the case.
Mercado Libre basically covers all of the region, it's most
important and largest markets and the objective is to cover
all the region as our focus is mainly Latin America.
We are the largest e-commerce site in the region and we are
the largest e-commerce site in everyone of the countries
that we operate as well. We are the eleventh largest retail
site in the world; this is according to Comscore. The
largest is Ebay, second Amazon, in terms of unique visitors,
very close to Ebay is Amazon, then Apple, Alibaba; that's a
Chinese site and we are the eleventh largest in the world.
In Latin America we are the first; we are three times larger
than the second. Similar in Brazil, we're the first e-
commerce site and Brazil is our largest market in the region
as well and we're the leaders there and we're the leaders in
every single country where we operate as well.
We're also one of the top internet destinations in the
region. We're the eight largest destination in terms of
unique visitors. So Microsoft is first, Google, Facebook and
we're eighth and in Brazil we are the ninth; so we are also
a popular destination there.
The way we have implemented our business; we have four eco
systems, what we're trying to create is a very powerful eco
system made up of four smaller eco systems that feed each
other. The largest businesses, our marketplace business and
I will review each one of these briefly. Then we have our
payments business and our advertising and web stores
business.
Our marketplace is basically the Ebay or Amazon type of
marketplace. It's interesting because we started being an
auction site of used stuff and today ninety six percent of
what is sold on our platform is fixed price and seventy five
percent is new stuff. So we have evolved the model quite a
bit; much closer to the Amazon marketplace. Having said that
we're also very strong in C to C, combine the Amazon
marketplace with craigslist, we're very strong in C to C as
well. The 25% that is not new is used stuff sold by
individuals where we are also leaders there. And that is
also a very attractive business to be in; the C to C.
We will the evolution of the figures so let me show you.
This is prior to 2002; we were embarrassed to show the
metrics but you can see very strong growth since last year,
we recently announced out yearly results. Last year we had
39 million transactions; that's an annual growth rate of 52%
during the eight years. I think this is close to twenty
times what we were in 2002. Last year we had fifteen million
buyers and sellers actively using our marketplace and that's
a figure that to me is very important.
We had 4 million people selling on our platform and we had
52,000 people who make a living selling on our platform. So
that's something that for me I'm very proud of. Typically
when I go to one of our subsidiaries I go and visit several
of our sellers and recently I've been very surprised by the
size and the professionalism that these sellers have.
Recently I was in Brazil with a seller who has 160
employees. And they solely sell on our platform, so we are
already enabling very large businesses. You have a question?
[Inaudible]
So the question is why is there such a big jump in paid
listings in the last year?
We have paid listings and we have free listings because more
recently we introduced the ability for sellers to list
something completely for free without any sort of fees and
it has been a great move. It was risky at first because we
didn't know how much it would cannibalize out own business
and it turned out that we obviously grew listings a lot but
we also grew revenues a lot because what we're doing is we'
re convincing sellers to list for free initially, to try the
platform but then to upgrade to paid listings. So it has
worked very well and we also improved our product quite a
bit in 2009 and 2010 and that enabled listing on our
platform much easier than what we used to do in the past.
In terms of gross merchandise volume; which is the value of
the stuff sold on our platform; we grew from 55 million in
2002 to 3.4 billion last year. This is like 60 X or 67%
compounded annual growth rate. So those are some metrics
that are interesting.
Obviously the businesses continue to grow very fast and as I
was saying before, because of the characteristics of our
industry, will continue to grow very fast for many years and
that's one of the reasons we introduced free listings.
Because there are millions of new users coming onto to the
internet in Latin America this year. Which is not what you
find for example in more mature markets like the States
where everyone has already been using the internet for a
while. In Latin American; you have millions of people that
are accessing the internet for the first time. So we didn't
want to have any barrier between these people and our
platform. So we are happy to have them list for free and
then the free listings have less traffic so if we that those
listings don't convert, we email them and tell them hey why
don't you try upgrading to a listing that has more
visibility?
Our second business model, our second eco system is our
payments platform; that operates very much like Paypal. It
used to be a closed platform, that it was only useful inside
Mercado Libre and it had an escrow component and the buyers
had to pay for the service because of the escrow service.
We've transformed that in our largest markets; Brazil,
Mexico and Argentina, to a Paypal type of model where it's
free for the buyers to use and it's growing very rapidly
both inside out platform and outside of our platform. In the
past, with the old version that we still have in our smaller
markets, you could not use out payment system outside of our
platform.
So we believe this is going to be a business that has the
potential to be bigger and we believe this business will be
bigger than Mercado Libre and we're seeing very rapid growth
there.
It's a very competitive business as well. We have local
competitors and regional competitors here.
These are some metrics for Mercado Pago you can see a very
big jump in the number of transactions processed and the
total payment volume in the last two years as we transformed
our business model and we improved our product.
There's also a big jump in the adoption with the percentage
of listings within Mercado Libre that offer Mercado Pago. A
big change that we did is we used to be like Paypal, that's
optional for the sellers to accept Paypal or not; now in the
countries where we have our new platform, it's compulsory to
use Mercado Pago and it doesn't have a cost for the seller.
The cost is imbedded in the Mercado Libre fee but every
seller has to offer Mercado Pago because we believe it's a
much better experience for the buyer and our objective is to
have 100 % of the transactions. We're at 20% currently or
this was the average for 2010, Q4 was closer to 30%. Yes?
[Inaudible]
It's hard to test some of these things. What we typically do
is we try it in a market and we see what happens, we
obviously look a lot at what's going on around the world and
if you look at the most successful marketplaces which in my
opinion is Itunes and the Amazon marketplace and more
recently the Android marketplace. In those marketplaces when
you buy you pay; there isn't a difference between buying and
paying. And in the Ebay marketplace and our marketplace
still today; there is a difference between buying and
paying. You buy and then you figure out with the seller how
you wish to pay and that creates a lot of friction, a lot of
hassle, it creates very high customer service cost for the
seller and for us. So it was quite obvious to us that this
is the way to go and we're going there but it creates a lot
of noise. When you have a big platform; four million people
selling on it and you create a big change like this, it
creates a lot of noise and you have to be able to maintain
your decision despite your noise. Ebay had a lot of those
problems some years ago when they started to do some
changes. I think Facebook is great at that, they make up
their minds about something and they do it and everybody
complains and they say, if they realize it's a mistake they
go back. But if you have an eco system with millions of
participants, you always hear lots of noise and you have to
be careful to separate the noise between what is actually
long term best for all the participants.
So this is our payment platform and very briefly Mercado
Clics and Mercado shops which are our two latest launches.
Mercado Clics is basically an adwords type of service. In
the past it was almost heresy to let people go outside of
our platform. So we didn't want anyone that was in Mercado
Libre to leave our site.
With the model we were very successful at attracting small
and medium size sellers to our platform. But we were never
really successful at attracting and retaining larger brands
to our platform, because they didn't want to list on our
platform next to the small and medium sized businesses that
competed with them and they also wanted to control the
overall buying experience. But through Mercado Clics, we
have been able to build very good relationships with very
large retailers that are happy to be on our platform. And we
also believe we are offering a better buying experience to
the buyers who are now able to see in once place the small
and medium size sellers and the abilities to also click away
from there and buy in the large retailer if they want to.
Sometimes they prefer to buy in large retailers because of
price, guarantees, brand recognition or special offers that
they may have. So it has worked very well for us. We're
obviously smaller than Google in the region but we are
growing very rapidly and we have over 11,000 advertisers
already, so this is a business that we believe has a huge
potential as well. And finally we launched Mercado Shops
which is a web front, web store solution and it's also
growing extremely rapidly, we launched it in the second half
of 2010 and we have already over 5000 web fronts, web stores
active. And this is basically the ability for anyone to do
e-commerce online and it comes integrated with Mercado Pago,
Mercado Libre and Mercado Clics; so it's very easy to
generate traffic to that store, if you have some inventory
that you want to sell in Mercado Libre because you're not
selling it in your platform; it's very easy to transfer the
inventory to Mercado Lbre and sell it there and vice versa.
And again it's a vision of having this full eco system where
each one of the parts helps the other.
And finally some financials for Mercado Libre in 2005, we
didn't dare go beyond 2005 so imagine what our revenues were
our first five years of operations; not very substantial.
But last year we had almost 220 million dollars of revenues
and 56 million dollars of net income. And recently in our
last earnings quarter we announced our first quarterly
dividend and the policies to pay out 25% of the prior year's
net income to the share holders. So it's a great feeling
eleven years later to give back to out shareholders; some of
the money that they have invested. So that concludes the
presentation and we can now open it up to questions.
When you created the company what were the major tweaks that
you created compared to the Ebay model?
Well we covered several of those but for the first few years
we really tried to recreate Ebay but then we saw that
several things didn't work. First of all people preferred
fix price to auctions so we moved to auctions very rapidly.
We've been at 90% plus fixed prices for the last eight, nine
years and Ebay is only at 60% fixed prices, going up because
they were three years ago at 40%. So I would say fixed
prices is a big one. The recent changes that we have done
with the payments; making Mercado Pago compulsory to other
sellers and we're moving forward to make the usage
compulsory, also to buyers I think it's going to be a big
difference. The way that we approach classifieds, we quickly
realized that people were not buying cats in auctions even
though they might or they were doing it in the US, we didn't
think that was the right model so we very rapidly did a
completely different business model for classifieds with
different pricing, different navigation, different search
and it worked very well. We are the leaders in motors in
every country and that's not the case for Ebay in the US.
There are very strong vehicle sites here in the US. So I
think those probably are the biggest tweaks. Sorry, finally
the free listings and the way that we have been able to
remain very strong and I would say leaders in classifieds.
Here you have craigslist which is very big and very strong.
You don't have anything, nowhere near to craigslist in Latin
America, even though free classifieds have existed there for
many years and I believe the reason is that we captured the
C to C segment better than what Ebay here. And more recently
allowing free classifieds, free listings has been a good
part of that.
Meg Whitman was actually here on Tuesday and she called a
decision to join venture with you as opposed to try and go
into the market; one of her best decisions as CEO of Ebay. I
was wondering from your perspective, what were the pros and
cons of receiving a secret investment from Ebay than having
them as a fairly significant shareholder?
Yeah I was with Meg last night and she told me she was here
a few days ago. So it was, for us it was a very big win to
partner with Ebay. When we signed, we knew it was going to
be good, we weren't sure why but we were willing to do it
almost at any price and we were lucky that Ebay didn't want
to consolidate our losses into their PNL. They wanted to be
under 20% of ownership. But we were willing to do it, not ay
any price, but we really wanted to a do a deal, we didn't
know exactly why, when we did it. We signed a best practice
sharing agreement and a non compete agreement. And the best
practice sharing which we didn't value that much at the time
ended up being extremely valuable. Because coming to the
quarterly meetings with Ebay and sharing knowledge with
them, learning from the things they were doing right and the
things that they were doing right was very advantageous for
us and I think it was also very helpful for them because we
didn't need their approval to do anything so we would go and
do things radically different to them and they would learn
from that as well. So I think it was mutually convenient.
Obviously the
[inaudible] o would prefer to not to get diluted 20% but
there's a price to everything.
[Inaudible]
Obviously the partnership has evolved a lot. When we signed
it we were almost like a subsidiary of Ebay. And the non
competing competition agreement expired five years ago, it
lasted five years 2001 to 2006. And now we compete, we
compete with their classified, we compete with Paypal. We
have a very good relationship with them; they're our largest
minority shareholder but they don't have a board seat. And
we have a very good relationship but we are also
competitors. Which is not unusual in our industry, we are
partners with Google, we are also competitors with Google
and Facebook etc.
You touched briefly on the tension between C to C and B to
C, can you talk some more on your strategy of how to keep
the marketplace open for C to C as
[inaudible]
Yeah I don't see those two things as conflicting even though
intuitively they look very conflicting; you say I have this
used mouse to see, how will anybody see that mouse if there
are 5000 mice being sold by Best Buy or other large
retailers? It's interesting but it gets sold anyhow. If you
have the right place. Obviously C to C have a way for them
to gain market share within our marketplace is to lower
prices. But the way the internet works, people don't
necessarily do a search and go page by page until they find
inventory. They access inventory through natural search in
Google. I don't know how they do it but they get to the
inventory and the 75/25 % mix has been relatively stable
across the different countries. So there is good liquidity
in the C to C marketplace as well even though free listings
are the ones that you see last as a buyer when you do a
search.
Question: I understand that the model is shifting a little
towards the Amazon business model. If this is true how are
you going to, are you going to warehouses to work more on
the logistics of the business?
That's a great question. We are not into logistics today and
we do not have plans to get into logistics ourselves, yet.
But that's something that we are looking at closely and we'
ll see what we need to do as the market evolves. But
currently what we are going to be doing is partnering with
the people that do logistics in the region and having them
do logistics for us but we plan to get involved much more
significantly in the shipping process than what we are
today. Today we're letting the seller solve shipping, each
seller might have a different solution; there's an
opportunity to get in the middle and negotiate better prices
on behalf of all of sellers and whenever there's a problem
have ourselves interacting with the logistics provider
rather than the different sellers. So there is an
opportunity to improve what we are doing and that's what we
are going to be working on in the next two years.
Basically with e-commerce there are two very large friction
payments. One is payments and the other one is shipping. We
believe payments; we are very close to solving it with these
things I was telling you were are doing with Mercado Pago.
And shipping is the next big thing for us to solve.
And we intend to solve it using a similar approach to the
one we have been using with payments.
Do you believe the Amazon model is feasible in Latin
America? Basically because sometimes infrastructure,
especially postal services tend not to be as solid and if
you were to apply it would you partner with people that are
already doing logistics? I've seen that Mercado Libre is
tweaking ever model and bringing it to Latin America, what
would be the necessary tweaks to make it work?
Well logistics in Latin America has many issues particularly
unions. So we are happy not to logistics and I think it's
going to be very difficult to get into logistics in Latin
America when you add the unions factor. Logistics unions are
very powerful in some of the countries. So we initially are
not intending to do it ourselves. Whether or not it's
feasible, I don't know. It's a question for someone like
Amazon to solve.
Question: Many of us are thinking of starting internet
companies after graduation. What are some of the common
mistakes that you would think we will make in our first year
of being in business?
Well I can tell you the ones we made. We thought we were
going to grow much faster than what we did. And it was
probably a consequence of the days when we launched, as I
said before, today things have changed dramatically, you see
companies like Groupon and
[inaudible] really scaling very fast because the internet is
much bigger and many of the bottle necks like payments have
been solved for them already. But we thought we were going
to scale much faster.
One thing I would do if I were to start again is whenever
you do a round of financing, secure more funding than you
think you might need, in case you don't grow as fast or you
have to spend more that what you thought. They be very
careful as to how you spend the money. I think one things we
did right, relative to everyone else in the region is we
really saved the money for the rainy days and then when the
bubble burst and no one was able to access capital any
longer and the business wasn't there because, when we
launched internet penetration, the region was 3%, today it's
close to 40%. So E-commerce which was 10% of the 3% is
really very small, so all o four competitors ran out of cash
and we still had 40 million dollars in the bank. So that was
important and I think the key, the most important thing for
technology start ups is to focus on the product and get the
product right and if there is something I regret it's not
having a stronger technology background, it's something that
I think Stanford should provide the GSB. You graduate here
knowing accounting and you can interact with an auditor and
discuss a PNL with them but you cannot interact with a
developer and discuss the way they have written code so
that's a big handicap for technology start ups. So I you
don't have that background like I did, I think it's
important to find a partner that has a very strong
technology background. Because that's the most important
thing; the product.
When you decided to start your company how did you go about
the decision process of incorporating
[inaudible] as opposed to going back to Argentina
[inaudible]
Well it's a way you want to live your life. There's no right
or wrong there. I was with my girlfriend, we wanted to go
back to Argentina so that's why we decided to go back. But
obviously it's an amazing place to live and do business in.
it's obviously more competitive as well, much more
competitive.
How are you overcoming the volume from Latin American
consumers to train online or to give their personal
information to an online platform.
[inaudible] tons of data from your consumers, what are you
as a company actually doing to limit that? And
[inaudible]
So the barriers, it's time and it's product. If you have a
good product people buy online and they don't see any virus.
Now with the new payments platform, the second time you buy
online, you do three clicks and your credit card is stored
there, your shipping address is stored there and it's really
easy, you see buyer's protection and people feel very safe
doing it and we have a very high repeat ratio of buyers that
come and buy again. So having a good product is helpful and
then it's time. Some people need some time, they hear from
their friends, I bought this on Mercado Libre, it's really
easy, it's very simple. An internet penetration increases
those barriers come down. And in respect to the data, I
think we could do a much better job using our data. We don't
intend to monetize the data, selling it to third parties or
things like that but one of the big things we are starting
to look at is doing the famous 'people who have seen this
have also bought that and people who have bought this has
also bought that' and we're just in the very early days of
that but to do that well you need to catalogue, structure
all the data. And our data was unstructured, our marketplace
data. So we've done a very big effort in building our own
catalogue of products trying to structure that data so we
know that people that bought exactly this mouse bought
exactly this monitor and not just any other monitor. So once
you have the catalogue, it's much easier to do those
recommendations.
What are the things that you did different from other
markets that made a difference?
As I said before, I think we focused much more on product;
less on PR and marketing, they are very good at that, we're
not good at that so we focused on product and we saved our
money and they spent it all. I think overall we had a long
term vision of building a company. And that's what I would
encourage anyone's who is thinking of doing a startup is to
have a long term vision of building a company, because you
have many difficulties along the way and if your motivation
is just to do an IPO or have an exit or sell the company,
it's not enough. Sometimes you need a lot of patience like
we needed and we had a long term vision of building a
company that added value to millions of people. I think that
was very powerful
[Inaudible]
Well we have a huge challenge because the technology
industry is incredibly competitive. So whatever you did
right in the past is probably a weakness today because you
have lots of legacy and we have lots of legacy. If you look
at the players in the US, there are very few internet
companies that started in 1999 when we started, that are
successful today and that's because technology wise it was
hard for them to adapt and we're in the process of adapting.
We have re-written all of our code to have an open platform
with API's and to enable third parties to develop on top of
our platform. That's something we didn't have, it's still
not live today and that's going to be a major change. So
basically transforming our technology is a big challenge and
if we do that well I think we have tremendous potential
because I believe the growth in next years is going to be
much faster than the growth in the last years.
So with Mercado shops, you've kind of gone away from your
own destination site to more of a distributed model. What
are your thoughts of that in the future? Is it going to
consolidate more or is it going to go more in the direction
of commerce everywhere out there? Where is it going to go?
It's going to go in the latter. Commerce everywhere. So if
you look at it Mercado Shops, Mercado Clics and Mercado
Pago, the
[inaudible] is also that so while Mercado Libre continues to
grow very rapidly and is our largest business, we believe
it's going to go towards and open model and that's why we
launched Mercado Shops. Mercado shops acts if you will as a
distributor of our payments platform and Mercado Clics, our
traffic generation platform. And also as Mercado Libre
because you can very easily transfer inventory from one to
the other. So Mercado Libre is becoming more and more of an
open platform as well. And with API's etc, the vision is to
have, let's say you list an item on our platform, it's like
listing a video on Youtube, then that item can appear as a
video on Youtube, anywhere, in any blog , you can see that
item anywhere and buy it. So that's a vision that we have
for Mercado Libre and that's the part of transforming our
technology that we're doing. Rather than going to Mercado
Libre to see this item or video you can see anywhere, you
can embed that item anywhere and even buy it anywhere; from
a mobile phone, from a tablet etc.
[Inaudible] what are you doing to raise those very raise
those very difficult barriers to allow commerce to flow?
There's very little cross border trade today. Payment is a
big part of solving that. But it's highly regulated and the
people doing it are not public companies that need to comply
with all the laws that we do. It's very complex to transfer
money from Argentina to Peru or from Argentina to Chile
without having many licenses in the region. So and then
obviously there are duties and customs. That's not our
focus. Our focus is the e-commerce that happens in each one
of the countries and we believe it's a huge market for that.
Hi. I wanted to know about how you started actually I mean
you can find the technical founder and as you said before
you need someone on your team that is technical. And do you
develop a prototype or something like that to show?
Yes, my cousin has a technical background and he started the
company with me. That's a fun story. We bought an auction
software from a company that was called 'OpenSite' it was
eventually bought by a larger player, I can't remember who.
They were in North Carolina and we bought it for 15,000
dollars. It was a terrible technology but it enabled us to
launch, we knew we were going to have lots of competition
and in the meantime we had our own developers doing our own
platform. But initially we bought an off the shelf software,
which we installed in the servers and we started with that.
You mentioned one of your goals is present in all of Latin
American countries. I was wondering why you have not
penetrated the few counties we se in Central America?
Partly it's because the technology that we have, that we are
changing, it's costly for us to do each country. Each new
country is costly so typically to add one feature in Brazil
has a better payoff than launching in Bolivia. But that's
the reason why we are completely overhauling our technology
so that we are able to launch in many more companies and
move much more rapidly than we have been in the past.
I get the sense that you move really fast.
[inaudible], I want to know if you were here today as a
student and you got an idea, you need to run as fast again
or will you wait? I mean it's case dependent...
If you're going to be in the technology industry you need to
run faster than you can. And that's why you need a great
team and basically it's very stressful and it doesn't stop,
it's always like that.
[Inaudible] if you setup the last ten years most of the
largest countries in Latin America are
[inaudible] how do you see the next ten years
[inaudible] proven business models here and there or is it
to invest in new business models?
I don't know it's a hard question to answer but what I will
say is it's very hard to replicate a business model in the
region because you cannot replicate it you need to adapt it.
There are many differences so that's what I would say.
[Inaudible]
Well there are many. Obviously the group buying stuff is
extremely hot and it's working very well over there as well.
Games on the internet; we do some payments for some gaming
companies in the region and they are growing very fast. The
biggest platform is
[inaudible] in Brazil but Facebook is growing very fast in
the region and in Brazil. So I see people doing very well in
those spaces and....
[Inaudible]
It's very tough to build it because you need to create scale
and it's very difficult to reach scale. I think that its
easier, well Check out now for Android for example and
Facebook credits, well they don't use real money, they just
use Facebook credit so in one way it's complimentary.
[Inaudible]
I don't know. I think there might be more than one but
probably the largest will have a substantial share of the
value created if you will. So probably there is going to be
more than one. If you look at the credit cards industry,
that's probably similar to what will happen online.
Within the technology sector or maybe beyond the technology
sector
[Inaudible] what is your opinion about that?
I see a lot more entrepreneurship in the region, endeavor
this foundation that selected us in 1999 has been doing an
amazing job in the region, through universities and working
with governments and everyone is very aware of how valuable
it is to have entrepreneurs in a country because they
generate mobile progress, mobility within a society and
innovation and jobs and so there's a very big focus on
entrepreneurship in other countries and I see many people
doing stuff so I think the environment is very good. And
there is venture capital, obviously it is not Silicon Valley
but it's a big change from what it was eleven years ago.
Talking about eleven years ago, I remember seeing the first
advertisement for Mercado Libre and I don't think I even
knew what online shopping was. And there really was a lot of
players, what was the strategy to differentiate yourself and
launch a brand when most people, even middle class had no
idea what online shopping was?
So I think what we wanted to do is do enough advertising to
make sure we would be amongst the survivors but do as little
as we could to save as much money as possible because we
knew that we were just throwing money out the window because
it was like saying, advertising something and then when
people go to the supermarket it's not there. Internet
penetration was 3% and TV, you target a 100% of the
population so straight away you're wasting 97% of the money.
We did very little TV but we did enough so that, because
interestingly enough the venture capital, I know the
financial community were the ones asking, pushing for people
to spend money, so we were like ok we have to do something
otherwise they won't invest in our round of financing
because they won't think we will survive. But we know that
this is not the way to go. I would definitely save that
money. It was a waste of money.
We have time for one more question if there is?
Thank you.